01 10
meu nome é carlos augusto pessoa que
conheceu o escritor e ilustrador e todos
os fiéis por cada um é e hoje é o que
vou conversar com vocês sobre o
principal tema é o tudo a temática deste
evento oferece está hoje reunido que é
que ele precisa passar o universo é um
quebra-cabeças e realmente é
é fantástico quando a gente vai ver o
quanto a gente vai pra ver tudo de
misterioso e fantástico universo a
biologia da silva nos oferecendo
mistérios e as respostas estão todas lá
pra ser encontradas a mesma coisa com a
química que também tem os seus vários
ministérios e todas as suas respostas
tão apercebem encontradas a mesma coisa
com a física que também tarde escondida
nos vários cantos do universo e com a
matemática cujo problema sempre acabam
tendo resposta então que o mais
fantástico é notar que o universo é
completamente encostado desses fãs desse
quebra-cabeça que estão lá fora a gente
em colocar as coisas mais incríveis
contundentes inspiradoras pessoas
libertadores formidáveis tudo isso
só saí inflação nessas e isso é bom
então é o universo tem tudo isso a gente
encontrar viajante procurar estamos mais
diversos fãs que a gente tentar resolver
a coisa é então o universo é cheio
desses quebra cabeças nas escolas pra
gente encontrar e tentar desvendar a
coisa mais interessante porém é que a
gente fala pouco do processo que a gente
chega a resposta destes quebra-cabeças
tanto da ciência biologia química física
quanto na matemática de tudo que se faz
da humanidade e muitas vezes esse comité
processo e é incrivelmente imperfeito e
nasce do acaso do acidente e muitas
vezes exatamente a quantidade de
criatividade que a gente está disposto a
colocar nele para conseguir alcançar a
sua resposta
o biólogo alexandre fleming ele
trabalhava no seu labor dólar com as
suas soluções e da índia ele saiu para
ter duas semanas de regras e ele foi lá
e voltou com um
ela estava suja que tinha nascido em
fuga em busca uma coisa que não sabia o
que era e daí antes de lavar e dvd pegar
da mulher com um microscópio gente isso
aqui está nascendo com placa de pedra e
ele olhou e descobriu que onde tinha
aquele músico as bactérias não estavam
se reproduzindo aquele curso é essa aqui
é a casa se deu porque ele é um pouco
relaxado com essas placas de raio x e
está fazendo alguns estudos para
descobrir novas maneiras de fazer num
dia e combos
sempre achei o unix aterros só que já
estava muito nublado e decidiu abandonar
minhas coisas eu estava um pouco à casa
da linguagem no pedacinho de papel que
não sabe o que quer e medindo papéis
ele deixou mais dor passou 23 dias e o
sol voltou e ele voltou a sair aos
upgrades dele acho que o trabalho dele e
descobriu que onde tinha guardado aquela
pedra tinha ocorrido à sua exposição o
raio-x tinha acontecido já li aqui é um
pedaço de urânio e ele descobriu ali foi
a primeira descoberta que a humanidade
fez sobre a radioatividade
então mais uma vez um acidente todo
mundo já ouviu falar também sobre o icex
milton é com netinho apple do rio de
janeiro não quer falar e vai acabar
margarina e deu super interessante ver
que muitas vezes expansão os fantásticos
e desafiadores do universo nascem a
resposta deles vem do acaso do acidente
uma coisa que não é pensada
o capitão da campeã e colo ele estima
que em 2010 50% de todas as descobertas
científicas feitas até hoje que tenha
sido um acaso tenha sido de alguém que
não sabia muito bem o que está fazendo
mas fiz mesmo assim acabou com uma coisa
maravilhosa acabou diz ela resolvendo
alguns dos seus muitos fãs do nosso
universo é um lugar onde isso mais
acontece com maior freqüência e com os
resultados mais incríveis pan é na arte
a produção artística por envolver na
criatividade ela sempre lida muito com
isso sua casa do acidente do inesperado
o bonde ano estava gravando o um dos
seus álbuns se ele estava quase
desistindo de fazer uma das músicas
o título é que foi a estônia na última
sessão onde ele ia gravar o que está
faltando
o governo está a reserva porque está
tudo errado e levou dentro da música em
todas as notas erradas e esta é a
questão que acabou do álbum do bloco de
gelo no local um estoque segundo a
revista uma missão né e melhor música de
todos os tempos porque é tão
porque a única porque ela nasceu o
acidente ela nasceu desse processo
criativo caótico que não tem como a
gente a circular não tem como a gente
controlar por exemplo um livro que
estava escrevendo uma carta de um amigo
dele e foi de cabeça que quer lá e
acabou escrevendo errado e saber o que
ocorre e daí nasceu a idéia mundo dos
livros nem falar em que foi campeão da
série b
as melhores obras de mulheres mais
inspiradoras mas mais tocantes viam
quando já não conseguia ver no seu
jardim
antes de ver a mesma coisa que o retorno
pode contar que começou a ficar surdo
aos 26 anos de idade e mesmo assim
conseguiu se dar muito bem e isso é a
coisa mais fantástica na arte ela pode
ser feita de várias bandeiras das
maneiras mais acidentais mais caóticas e
um processo é completamente imprevisível
e o resultado muitas vezes é maravilhoso
e uma das maravilhas da arte que não tem
resposta certa pode pegar e desenhar
urbana como leonardo da vinci picasso ou
como blogs lei ou como jesus ou como o
penta antológico e acordoar de aventura
então é interessante
então é interessante ver todos esses
desenhos aqui é duarte é tudo muito
legal muito bonito muito criativo está
tudo certo de arte funciona assim
então eu não consigo falar bastante eu
acho importante ressaltar a importância
da gente fazer arte é a gente se
pergunte pra gente se dá o trabalho de
passar um pouco com esse processo
criativo caótico e fazer um pouco de
arte seja uma música o filme uma poesia
qualquer coisa né porque daí seja
conversão como hobby como terapia porque
a gente vai aprender vai começar a lidar
com isso o processo do acidente do caos
de fazer um erro mas de encontrar num
erro uma possibilidade a manipular o
acaso a se adaptar ao inesperado ao medo
incitamento trauma do fracasso buscá-los
a 11 anos
então faz palestras em escolas e tal uma
vez eu estava andando uma palestra e
depois aparece o menino foi rapidinho
comprar um livro veio perguntar com
garras e de fotografar como também fácil
esquecer e pensar que com desenhos e
desenhos da io assim em volta e não sei
da itália
acha que vai gostar ele olhou assim ele
um ventilador de avintes agora né
outra coisa ele hoje há uma caneta
também eu queria que eu não caí na época
do gost nem falou mas o vizinha coisa
que existe é uma coisa muito legal
comecei a fazer palestras fazer uma
palestra onde eu cheguei e fiquei
falando na frente eu estou fazendo hoje
mas se realmente pegar e de ter um
momento de interação de relatar o que
vocês querem criar você tem que fazer um
imaginário como casamento gay como é que
olho comércio não contava a história
começa quando um personagem para o
veículo então através desse uso de troca
é onde acontecem pra mim as descobertas
mais incríveis porque é através desse
processo caótico de troca de movimento
que não tem como controlar que a gente
consegue chegar a soluções mais
fantásticas dos famosos mais inesperados
porque afinal né a arte é exatamente
isso é tentativa é erro é diversão em
crescimento é aprendizado e universo é
um plano é o universo gigantesco
quebra-cabeça e o que a gente tem que
fazer é buscar oportunidades nesses
erros nesses acidentes esperança na
desesperança e vitória na derrota
o franco o pastor desculpas disse
que há a chance favorece a mente
preparada que eu acredito que o melhor
jeito de preparar as nossas mentes pelo
erro irá transformar esse erro na
vitória é fazendo arte
então muito bem